all right and that PAX Prime 2014 well I
got a chance to play civilization beyond
Earth and I you know me I love a good
civilization game my first gamer B was
actually civilization 5 the civilization
beyond Earth
I was digging right in but this was
actually kind of difficult you can't
really compare this to another
civilization game you're on a completely
different world so you don't create fire
and then go to the wheel and then find
coal you have all the tech that's sent
you to space I'm in space trying to
survive this world you're get you have
satellites right out the gate you have
weapons right out the gate your workers
to look like the thing that Ripley told
the Queen alien to get away from her you
[ __ ] and everything he's just bigger I
I was planted in the most hostile
environment ever all the weeds around me
were killing my guys like my little guys
were going out there immediately losing
10 life it's a really hostile
environment you're on Pandora I found
aliens like these little insects look at
aliens I was like we do what Quaritch
would do we scrape a lot when we kill
them cuz they're gonna be like the
barbarians but it wasn't like that
the girl who was there was like no no
actually they're they're sentient beings
and you just waste war on them because
they interact with you how do you
interact with them so I pissed off the
entire indigenous population of this
world
they're not like barbarous you get
they'll work with you they get they'll
treat you fine but they don't
discriminate and so if you you're
playing against someone who's next to a
nest you can piss them off they're like
all humans suck and they'll just start
tearing them up and you're like that's
how I do it because I'm manipulative me
I learned I'm a terrible leader the
entire planet got wiped we all died the
technology tree it's completely it's not
like a tear that goes down to a tear
that goes down to tear that goes down to
here it is literally a spider web you
look at it it goes everywhere so like
yeah you're already smart you have
science that sent you to Shh chase I'm
looking forward to this game
it's next level [ __ ] if ever there was
one it doesn't feel like more the same
civilization it feels like civilization
next level I'm gonna get many work days
are gonna disappear because of this game
did you guys know you play that [ __ ] at
work you know you I did
I don't know to say my boss is watching
I played civilization at work for eight
straight hours in the day disappeared I
have no regrets and here we are I'm
under the ball sack under the camel toe
of a giant monstrosity this is what we
call evolved evolved it's a first-person
shooter
harken back to alien vs. predator - like
back in the day from PC pretty much the
same thing you have a bunch of people
all of them of a different class you got
a hunter support medic trapper and you
have to take on another player one of
your other friends playing as the
monster and you guys hunt this thing
down this thing is growing it's evolving
and becoming big you have to use your
abilities together to kill this big
[ __ ] bastard it's really hard because
the worst part is or the best part is
that it's a person and so it's sentient
your friend knows how to optimize his
moves so this thing is harder than most
computer NPCs that are trying to kill
you
one thing I noticed I will say that this
is what I call a LAN party game alright
I'm not gonna play a ball all the time
I'm not gonna sit down but I have to
plate your ball team but when my friends
are over and we link together our PCs
you know that just coming out and you
know what's going down it's a lot of fun
and do the assault guy your friend who's
the monster is going after view the
assault knives so you pretty much have a
target on your head but that's alright
it makes you feel special and [ __ ]
unfortunately I don't have any monster
footage because I didn't get to play as
a monster and so they could record what
we play but only your footage like
people have exclusive rights to it so
there's no monster footage on here but
there is footage of me dying and that's
pretty cool
so evolve I here it is I have a friend
who will get involved he's the guy off
rating the camera right now and he's
smiling cause he knows he's gonna get
involved I'll play his copy and when we
land up I'll probably end up getting
involved